what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
oh my god Rob core man man let me tell
y'all something this story dude like
it's night man this story is so good if
God was right in Green Lantern right now
that's what it would look like right now
it's one of the best stories that I've
ever seen ever read in the history of
comic books do this story so amazing so
blackest night is as much like a soft
reboot as it is just like this amazing
epic because remember blackest night
basically focuses on the resurrection of
like all these dead superheroes kind of
a resurrection is sort of a weird
situation
but blackest night really is like this
next stage of Jeff John's run on Green
Lantern and this has been a long time
coming keep in mind the Green Lantern I
guess landscape has progressed over the
course of the entire you know series
that we've done so far which we cover
every Sunday the idea is that it all
started with like Sinestro Corps Award
right like Thal Sinestro formerly a
Green Lantern abused his powers he was
banished
he found a yellow lantern it basically
had a yellow Lantern ring created for
himself and then formed his own core
this led as a direct conflict between
the Green Lantern's and the Sinestro
Corps but the idea was that this was
really rooted in the character of a band
sewer Aven sewer was a Green Lantern he
was the one who died on earth and gave
his ring to Hal Jordan but Aven soar had
been told of the prophecy of blackest
night' by a being named Atrocitus
Atrocitus that looked into the future
and saw that there was going to be this
massive war of light and the black
lanterns would rise and extinguish all
life across the universe but the
guardians of the universe saw this is
fear-mongering Atrocitus was a guy who
made the Red Lantern Corps and so the
idea was that because Green Lantern's
have to overcome fear in order to be
able to use their powers that this was
all just a tactic used by Atrocitus for
the purpose of weakening Aven sword so
he could be defeated because of this
almost none of the Guardians took it
seriously the only two who did were
ganthet and sayd and in order to protect
themselves from the prophecy of blackest
night and to ensure that there would be
some sort of way to win they formed the
Blue Lantern Corps and so at that point
it was just a waiting game we had the
blue lanterns there we had the Indigo
tribe this super mysterious Lantern
Corps who we didn't really know anything
about you had the star sapphires who
were a lantern court rooted in love you
had the Green Lantern's you had the
Sinestro Corps that was kind of out
there somewhere and then you had the red
lanterns and that was really about it I
mean it was just okay now we're just
having these store
we're just waiting until blackest night
happens but all of this really stems
from a guy named William hand this guy
is a dude who was just obsessed with
death but because all the different
lanterns are Lantern cores that exist
out there have entities basically these
living embodiments of their respective
emotions de living embodiment of death
is a being named necron and this is the
person that William hand basically
warships but the idea here is that this
all initially kicks off with William
hand literally going to the grave of
Bruce Wayne and taking his skull now
this comes immediately out of Final
Crisis and we have not covered Final
Crisis just because of the fact that
that story is an exercise in the
absolute befuddle meant and
mind-boggling of why a person would
write a story like that but the long and
short of Bruce Wayne's involvement in
Final Crisis is that the villain
Darkseid one of the new gods had
basically sought to dominate all things
in existence by using the anti-life
equation at the end of the story Bruce
Wayne fired a killing shot at Darkseid
Darkseid uses Omega sanctions which
should have just killed Bruce Wayne
instead he was actually time-displaced
which is one of the roles this story
serves to basically show us that Bruce
Wayne's not dead but everyone believes
he's dead and so because of this of
course he's been buried at Wayne Manor
so on and so forth and the idea is that
in the face of Bruce Wayne being
believed to have been dead we end up
having all these black Lantern rings
which are just sent out across the
entire universe now what this does is
this switches over to Coast City and
this is kind of a cool thing because
again all this really goes back to like
Hal Jordan becoming parallax for those
of you guys who are new to the whole
Green Lantern landscape and coast city
plays a really significant role not just
because of its location but because of
the place that it has within the realm
of the superhero community the coast
city is the basically the main base of
operations the main city for Hal Jordan
is really like his home more or less and
the idea was that back in the 1990's DC
wanted to get rid of Hal Jordan they
wanted to remove him from the equation
and replace him with a new Green Lantern
so what nice he did is they wrote a
story called Emerald Twilight an emerald
Twilight came out of the death of
Superman we had Superman dying at the
hands of doomsday we had four new
supermen who popped up on the scene one
of these was a guy named cyborg and the
idea was at cyborg superman alongside a
villain named Mangal attached KO city
and
the result was that when Hal Jordan came
back from a mission in space he found
everything he knew and loved completely
obliterated what this did is it left him
open to exposure to fear basically he
lost his ability to overcome fear for a
temporary amount of time but in that
small window it allowed the living
embodiment of fear named parallax to
enter Hal Jordan now the idea of
parallax entering Hal Jordan possessing
him that was a Geoff Johns change that
was not something that we learned until
like 2006 2007 but the idea was that at
the time it was basically how Jordan
just becoming a bad guy and so what
ended up happening here is how Jordan
basically just laid waste to the
entirety of the Green Lantern Corps it
was a massacre like nothing we'd ever
seen before
he ended up destroying all the Green
Lantern's he killed all the guardians of
the universe except for one and so what
ended up happening is that with Hal
Jordan basically mainlining the
willpower emotion and mainlining fear he
basically became God just started
calling himself parallax now with us did
is it led to the last remaining guardian
of the universe ganthet traveling to
earth and giving Kyle Rayner a ring and
that's where Kyle Rayner ended up
becoming the Green Lantern that's how
his whole origin story comes into play
but the idea here is that because Co
City was being rebuilt as part of Geoff
Johns run on the Green Lantern stories
what this does is it brings us to its
conclusion which is to say Coast City
has been fixed now Coast City has been
repaired people are starting to move
back it's this whole revelation that
Coast City is the place to be now and
it's a celebration of a multitude of
different things this also comes on the
holiday that's basically been created as
a result of Superman's death when
Superman died at the hands of doomsday
back in the 1990's the superheroes of
the DC Universe basically christened
that as a holiday when he came back it
was the day of Superman's death the day
of Superman's return so on and so forth
and so that became like this national
event but what ends up happening is we
get this sort of rundown about all these
different instances of people who have
died people who have loved others who
have lost the ones they loved it's
really kind of this day to remember all
the most important things in life but to
also honor those individuals who have
died and so again is touching on these
various characters these various
individuals who have played roles in the
realm of the superhero community one of
the more notable instances is Aquaman
Arthur curry following the event of
Infinite Crisis basically the story
brought the multiverse back after crisis
on Infinite Earths DC had a series of
comics called 52 but they also had
something called the missing year and
the idea was that after Infinite Crisis
Aquaman was gone nobody knew where he
was now the intention of DC at the time
was to actually kill him was to have him
dead and gone forever but Aquaman
despite the legacy of being the guy that
quote-unquote talks to fish fans still
loved him and fans wanted him to return
so we ended up making his debut what
this ends up doing is it still leaves
out there the idea that Aquaman is dead
not only that it actually solidifies the
belief that Aquaman's dead in the sense
that with Meera and with Garth basically
you know Aqualad more or less talking
about the the death of Aquaman and
overlooking his grave and so on and so
forth he actually ends up reimbursing
he's one of the one of these other
people who pops up during the whole
event of blackest night which is to say
a person who has a black Lantern ring
now he's not the first person we see I
just kind of throw it in there because
we were talking about Aquaman anyway
what we actually end up doing is picking
up with Barry Allen again one of the big
revelations that came during Final
Crisis is that where Barry Allen was
believed to have died during crisis on
Infinite Earths
and it only ever really popped up once
in a while in terms of like a flashback
or something along those lines
what Final Crisis revealed and what
flash rebirth the original flash rebirth
revealed was at Barry Allen never died
Barry Allen merged with the Speed Force
and in the 20-some odd years or even
longer than that the 25 years that it
that he had basically been missing from
DC Comics in truth he'd actually been in
the Speed Force outrunning death
constantly and so because of that during
Final Crisis Barry Allen re-emerged and
it was one of the coolest moments ever
because it's like Jay Garrick and I
think Wally West and like one other
person there there you know and like a
portal opens up and it's just like Jay
Wally would like Barry Allen comes
running out of this portal and like I'm
worried and it was like holy cow who is
hilarious because if you go and look at
message boards back in 2009 people were
just like watch people were freaking out
because Barry Allen returned and it was
one of the crazy things but the other
half of this is that with Barry Allen
being alive one thing to keep in mind is
that his return basically comes after 25
years of being absent and so literally
how Jordan catches him up on everyone
who's died over the last 25 years
whether it was a day ago or it was 25
years ago and this includes a lot of
people it includes John Jones Martian
Manhunter Black Canary Dodd Aquaman
includes all these characters Barry had
fought alongside during his years when
he was a superhero and so learning all
of this but we also end up finding out
is that the Justice League is not
without honor the Justice League
actually ended up taking the corpses of
people whose identities as villains were
known and basically keeping them in the
Hall of Justice giving them an honorable
burial now the other half of this really
deals with what's going on out in space
which is to say the war of light
remember while all this is taking place
on earth all the other Lantern cores are
out fighting basically all the Green
Lantern's that exist out there with the
exception of like Hal Jordan on earth
they're all atoms space they're all
fighting against the zamarons the star
sapphires the Sinestro Corps I mean
they're basically engaged in this
massive war of light and that's what the
guardians begin to comment on none of
these guys believed it was real none of
these guys believed that the war of
light was going to happen none of them
believed the blackest night prophecy was
actually going to come to fruition but
faced with this war of light faced with
the Green Lantern's fighting the red
lanterns fighting the blue lanterns
finding the Indigo's fighting the star
sapphires fighting the Sinestro Corps
faced with all of that the guardians of
the universe now have to come to accept
the fact that the war of light is
happening the problem with this is that
it's preparing for an earthquake after
the earthquakes already started it's too
late and so at this point they're
literally just under damage control but
what little hope they have in trying to
stave off this war of light or at the
very least trying to come out on the
winning side is almost completely swept
away when the scarred Guardian reveals
her allegiance to the black Lantern's
remember after the events of Sinestro
Corps war there were these small things
that happened here and there in the
Green Lantern story that all led into
this all led into this blackest night
run this is essentially the first strike
in this instance one of the Guardians is
killed by the scarred Guardian the rest
are imprisoned and the shield around OA
is brought down and what this does is it
allows these Black Lantern rings to just
start flying and just begin bonding
themselves to all these dead Green
Lantern's and resurrecting them if you
guys haven't grasped it by now all hell
is breaking loose this is crazy Katie
bar the door
the it's man man this is why I say the
story so good man Jeff Josh why do you
have to write such damn good stories oh
like things are just popping off and
that's what people are basically coming
to coming to
realize here kyle rayner Kilowog Guy
Gardner these guys who are like you know
members of the Green Lantern Corps out
there in space Barry Allen Hal Jordan
they're coming to the realization that
all these dead superheroes are coming
back as black Lantern's and that's
what's so cool about this because what
is up happening is we basically have all
this pandemonium taking place now
another thing to keep in mind are the
characters of elongated man and soo
Divini Sudanese character really gained
like her biggest moment in DC Comics
when she was killed by Jean Loring
during the events of identity crisis now
that's a story that we haven't covered
yet just because it's so controversial
it's a pretty dark story it's it's
pretty pretty crazy but it basically
deals with like mind why being different
things like that but the idea here is
that elongated man essentially died
during countdown to Final Crisis I think
it was and so they've been gone for
quite some time soo did me having
already been killed and so this is
basically bringing those characters back
for kind of a short stent now they have
like pretty significant roles in the
hearts and minds of a lot of DC fans
everywhere a lot of DC fans are just
like yeah man Ralph did me I don't know
what he did outside of identity crisis
but I remember that I remember Sudeep me
during identity crisis but I don't know
anything about her outside of that which
is flying because a lot of people latch
on to characters during particular
stories the idea here is that this is
essentially different people trying to
deal with the emergence of these black
Lantern's all at the same time now with
Aquaman with him popping up as a Black
Lantern this basically goes into him
killing off a multitude of his soldiers
attempting to take mera as his queen and
then using his powers to literally just
kill almost everybody else around him
now of course this also introduces the
death of Garth but again this is when we
started getting into this whole soft
reboot thing the reason for this is
because of the fact that with like
elongated manage to didney for example
they end up showing up and they kill
Hawkman and they kill Hawk woman and
then they basically turn him into black
Lantern's but the idea was for DC to
essentially kill off all these different
characters and then say okay with all
these characters quote-unquote being
dead here's the ones that were gonna
bring back and so it was essentially
kind of a soft reboot you know it was
better than simply having like Hawkman
walked down the road and gets shot in
the face and they're like the death of
Hawkman like it was a lot more
interesting than that so it kept things
interesting and kept them going smoothly
but it also allowed DC to get rid of
characters that either weren't popular
or theirs
weren't selling or what-have-you but one
of the other things that we end up
learning is that these characters who
were dead and are being quote-unquote
resurrected are not their real cells and
that actually comes from a guy named
Boston brand now dead man is a guy who
basically just goes around in habit
embodies his takes over people he's part
of that whole DC vertigo mysticism magic
he's part of all that that storyline
that goes over there but the reason why
this matters is because dead man
actually shows up as a black lantern
while simultaneously existing as as
normal self and so what this means is
that these black Lantern's that are
running around as superheroes are not
actually resurrected superheroes instead
they're basically duplicates but the
reason why this matters and the reason
why didn't show up the way they do is
pause for concern is because in order
for them to basically begin rising in
order for them to essentially charge the
central power battery to 100% they meet
people who are in various emotional
states and then they need to consume
their hearts and so what this does is
with them emerging with these various
superheroes faced with teammates friends
former lovers who are believed to have
been resurrected from the dead as evil
lanterns then suddenly it starts putting
them into this emotional state of fear
or rage or something along those lines
and because they're so charged with
emotional energy they take their hearts
they consume them and the entire Black
Lantern Corps is even more empowered
because of it now one of the biggest
moments of the Black Lantern Corps comes
in the form of the spectre remember the
spectres basically the representation of
God's vengeance but the spectre is one
of these characters in DC Comics who's
about as close as we get to DC's
iteration of like the cosmic entities
remember Marvel deals with things like
the representation of the universe how
long it takes from the time the universe
was made to the time that it ends that
timespan they have like cosmic entities
for that they have cosmic entities that
represent the entirety of the universe
they have cosmic entities that represent
all these different things DC plays it a
little more realistic DC plays it as
okay so there's the presence there's
basically God in the DC Universe then
there's like Lucifer Morningstar
basically Satan but the reason why this
matters is because these characters
these higher pantheon of characters in
DC are largely considered to be so
astronomically powerful that they're
well beyond the capabilities of any
traditional superhero but then in the
face of these black Lantern's emerging
these rings bonding themselves to
people one of the Rings takes over and
corrupts the specter and so what this
means is that the power of the Black
Lantern rings is basically of the
highest echelon of the highest order
that no one can withstand the power of
these ranks the reason why this matters
is because this is Geoff Johns basically
saying no one's safe there's no safe
haven but he does provide one exception
the only exception he provides to this
are individuals who died and are at
peace and so what it basically seems to
indicate is that the only individuals
who can be resurrected or who can
basically be copied by the Black Lantern
rings our individuals who died under
grudging circumstances people who died
unwillingly and so because that it
allows them to basically be copied to
re-emerge and it just sends things
spiraling almost out of control now of
course this also breathes in to fray the
superheroes doing the best they can
because again when you're faced with
power like this it's not a matter of
overcoming than by traditional means
it's a matter of just running like hell
and hoping you survive another day and
in this instance this is brought to us
by virtue of Barry Allen and Hal Jordan
remember Barry Allen is a chemist as
much as he has the flash and it's not
very often that you see those two things
go hand in hand
you usually see that aspect of his
personality when he's doing his normal
job as a forensic investigator but his
cool seeing him in this instance because
as we know with Martian Manhunter his
biggest weakness is fired and so it
makes sense to Barry Allen to basically
to start dousing him surrounding him
with chemicals and then when Hal Jordan
throws a car in and the car blows up
everything catches a flame that Martian
Manhunter would be weakened the problem
with this is that that's not the case
instead Jon Jones Martian Manhunter
emerges just like he did before and so
what this does is again this sets the
stage by saying that the traditional
weakness of superheroes as they existed
before they became black Lantern's is
not really effective here instead you
have to defeat them as black Lantern's
as opposed to how they used to be now
from here we actually end up
transitioning to a guy named Jason Rusch
and to a girl named I guess it's Jenny
it's felt really weird it's like geh n
EE or something like that but the idea
here is that this was DC's attempt to
basically reinvigorate the whole concept
of firestorm remember Ronnie Raymond is
firestorm had been that way for quite
some time and it's one of the most
popular iterations of his character and
this instance is actually Jason and this
girl Ginny we're gonna go ahead and call
her that who basically inhabit the same
body or at least who will become the
firestorm concept the issue with this is
that Jason had basically merged with
several people before this so it was
literally DC grabbing him and saying
okay Jason Rusch will be the main
firestorm person and then we'll grab
whoever else and see which person fans
liked the most the issue was that Ginny
was not really a character fans enjoyed
too much so they actually end up killing
her off in this story but again one of
the other things that we end up learning
is that the the Black Lantern ring
cannot just be removed by traditional
means instead the rings actually grow
roots down into the person they are part
and parcel so trying to remove the ring
is almost impossible because the ring
will come back that person is part of
the Black Lantern Corps and they will
stay that way unless a tried and true
means of taking them down can actually
be found and so because of this you know
with Jason Rusch with Jenny basically
going through the investigating as best
they can
of course we end up finding out that
they were summoned to the Hall of
Justice by Mira herself the wife of
Aquaman and that's really where this
story begins to hit home because what
this is is just escaping it's them just
fleeing for their lives now of course
this also coincides with the arrival of
the Indigo tribe now remember the Indigo
tribe are very mysterious but one of the
reasons why the Indigo tribal are so
powerful is because they can tap into
and manipulate other Lantern cores and
so in this instance indigo one the
leader of the Indigo tribe is actually
able to separate one of the black
lanterns from their rings using a
combination of the Indigo tribes power
and the Green Lantern's power so again
what this does is it actually tells
everybody else who's there that being
able to defeat the black Lantern's
basically comes through combining powers
together and trying to take them out but
that's a stopgap measure all it's really
going to do is solve things temporarily
what they need is a tried and true
measure of bringing the black lanterns
down and the cool thing about this if
geoff johns teases it to us Jeff John
actually tells us something called the
white light and what he basically says
is that in the beginning of all things
there was simply just white light there
was just white that's all there was but
eventually the darkness essentially you
know overrule the light it took over and
it led to the creation of all life the
emotional spectrum and so on and the
white light fragmented and so what this
means is that the white Lantern ring as
most people know by now is effectively a
combination of all the Lantern rings
communal
brought together at least one of each
Lantern ring combined into one and that
of course will be the means by which
they end up winning I mean I don't mind
throwing that out there
because this story came out like eight
years ago so most people know what's
going on with regards to this but again
you know at this point it's just a
matter of trying to get away it's just a
matter of trying to win now of course
this leads to Ginny basically being
killed off and again fans didn't really
enjoy her too much she was mysterious DC
never really expanded on her and so
because of that they ended up killing
her character off and it leaves a
landscape open for Jason to merge with
someone else and so in the face of all
this because of the fact that the black
Lantern's are continuing to rise in
prominence the question becomes where's
Superman where's Wonder Woman where are
these superheroes that were most
familiar with who we would think would
at the very least be here in the midst
of this conflict but we're not
immediately told and in fact there's
actually tie-ins for those characters
which we are going to cover but in the
face of recognizing that accommodation
of Green Lantern energy among other
forms of energy can temporarily defeat
individual members of the Black Lanterns
it then becomes basically Barry Allen
running around broadcasting this
information to everyone who's out there
and so this is when we find out that
Wonder Woman is fighting these black
Lantern's that all these different
characters who exist out there the
Titans the Teen Titans that they're all
facing off against these black Lantern's
doing the best they can not only that is
also this revelation that individuals
like dr. fate are black Lantern's dr.
fate of course again being the
predecessor tomorrow's Doctor Strange
but again these are all great moments
Power Girl Alan Scott the Green Lantern
of Earth to all these characters are
facing off against the best they can't
to hold off against unstoppable odds and
so as this section the video begins to
wind down
what is up happening is the Black
Lantern central power battery is
teleported to coast city by the scarred
Guardian and what we end up finding out
is that with the central power battery
charged at 100% what it does is it
allows the living embodiment of death
the entity known as Necron to enter into
the earthly plane to enter into the main
DC Universe and make his presence known
while simultaneously resurrecting every
single person who's ever died in Co City
and dragging them into the Black Lantern
Corps would that be sad guys
go ahead and burn this video to an end
man I love the story if you are new here
to comment explain make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the Rob pork if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you